the pandemic has of course put a huge
strain on the nhs and resources
prioritized to tackle people dying from
covert
but that of course means that waiting
lists for other kinds of treatment have
grown from cancer care to mental health
so let's talk about this with the shadow
health secretary jonathan
ashworth who joins us from leicester and
by prioritizing covid have we take an
hour off the ball when it comes to
other important health conditions
well it's understandable as to why we
had to prioritize
covid because to be frank if you under
fund your
nhs over many years if you cut beds if
you
try and run your nhs with vacancies for
a hundred thousand staff
and you cut training you cut public
health you cut
social care that means when a crisis
like this hits
you're more exposed and vulnerable but
we shouldn't have to make a choice
between covered care
and cancer care but that's what we've
been doing and today
we're missing all their targets or the
main targets for cancer care
we've got a huge backlog in our waiting
list over
300 000 people now waiting beyond 12
months for treatment
it was 1600 a year ago this is risking
lots of livelihoods and permanent
disability for some it's risking
loss of life so we're saying to the
government we need an nhs
rescue package we need a plan to put the
funding into the nhs
but crucially we need a plan now to
recruit the staff
that we're going to need for the future
to deliver the quality care that
patients deserve
um now we've been talking a lot about um
covered
and of course the coronavis act later on
uh this week that everyone's gonna be
voting on steve baker
earlier on the program said that labour
would vote for any old authoritarian
measures so he expects you to vote in
favor of extending
the app for another six months um is he
right
well i don't i don't agree with the way
he's characterized it and of course
he voted and lots of conservative mps
voted for
lots of photo authoritarian measures
last week in the house of commons
that whether we like it or not the virus
is still
circulating we had alright we're having
we've got around 6 000 infections
a day that is a high level of virus
circulating
it's much less than where we have been
obviously but it's still quite dangerous
out there
so yes vaccination is rolling ahead and
is is succeeding
but we still have to be cautious we
still have to proceed
carefully we have to be driven by the
data and that will mean i'm afraid that
governments
will have to have the powers to impose
restrictions where necessary so there
are bits of that act
which need to be properly scrutinized
and haven't actually been implemented
and i'm going to be asking matt hancock
why certain elements of that act around
social care continuing health care needs
to remain
on the statute book but there's other
elements in that act which i believe
are needed governments do need to be
able to impose restrictions
governments do need to pay statutory
sick pay from day one
i'd actually like them to go further and
pay more sick pay and governments
do need to stop people being evicted
from their homes if they can't pay the
rent
because of the because of their
livelihoods have been uh
so hit by this pandemic so say your face
next piece of language
it's a complex piece of legislation we
will we broadly support it
it ought to be properly scrutinized i
mean i think what is frustrating is that
steve baker who i think will have
tremendous respect for
should be given the opportunity to put
forward amendments to the act
but the way in which the government
timetable these these uh
deliberations means he's denied that
opportunity
this act okay it was emergency
legislation a year ago it should be
properly scrutinized now and if steve
baker and graham brady wants to work
with us
to get the house of commons to agree a
proper process
to to thoroughly scrutinize our act so
we can all put forward amendments
i'd be happy to sit down with him
tomorrow to see if we can find that
procedure
um you're clearly concerned about um the
way ahead
you say that we shouldn't take our foot
off the the pedal if you like
um and there are rising cases in europe
as well what is your position
on summer holidays are they something
that needs to be sacrificed
in order to keep cases low here
well i've always said we have to proceed
with caution
we have to study the data at every stage
because sadly and i don't want to
be to disappoint the viewers but just
vaccination in the whole of the united
kingdom while important
and will save lives does not make us
bulletproof
it does not make us completely safe we
are only safe
when everybody is safe so so long as the
virus appears to be surging in france
and germany and parts of europe
which it is at the moment because this
is their this is their b117 wave
that's the kent variant that we've had
our kent variant wave
if you like their converient wave is now
surging
so we are not safe while the virus
circulates in these huge numbers across
the world
and of course we run the risk that more
variants more mutations emerge
which bounce back and hit us and
potentially evade the vaccine success
that we have had
so that it's a long long way to answer
your question is that
it's too early to make a judgment around
the may 17th
date on international travel i would
argue
i'm not expecting myself to go on on a a
holiday abroad this summer but we'll
obviously
keep these things under review and we
have to continue to do all we can
to squash the infections down and
protect the successful vaccination here
in the united kingdom
well after speaking to you and ben
wallace this morning it does feel like
maybe
holding back on booking that foreign
holiday might be a good move
just finally while i have you labour
have selected
the former mp paul williams to fight the
hartlepool
by-election uh he was on an all-male
all-white shortlist of one
in the labour party is everyone a
feminist until he doesn't see it anymore
say that again so i should say that
again sorry in in the labour party is
everyone
as feminist as long as it suits you and
then stops
well we're still committed to all women
shortlists and improving the
representation
of women in parliament we've actually
got more than 50 percent i think
of women in the parliamentary labour
party because of because of all women's
shortlists and we're very proud of that
and we will continue to use
all women shortlists in in parliamentary
selections
uh and future by-election selections
just not this one
well i wasn't involved in this i mean
i'm not i'm not on the label of any c
who takes these decisions i'm pretty
busy dealing with our covered response
to be honest but we will you
we will use all women shortlists in
other parliamentary selections i've got
absolutely no doubt of that
okay jonathan ashworth thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning thank you